en méxico lo que ganamos no alcanza para
la comida para escuela de los niños para
vestir calzar para todo es muy difícil
en chile
[Música]
y angustiante porque lo que antes que
alcanzaban para el mes
hoy día llegar al día a
1520 en brasil
los pobres solo pueden comer pescado
salchichas y julio pueden olvidarse de
la carne si una pandemia y ahora una
guerra los países de américa latina
notan el alza del precio de los
alimentos y de los combustibles en perú
han registrado la inflación más alta en
25 años como el perú importa combustible
como el perú importa alimentos la
inflación se mete y eso o sea también en
programó un poco con el deterioro de las
expectativas de los peruanos sobre la
inflación en el futuro
bien saben de inflación en argentina
donde la cifra anual supera el 50% por
lo que esperan que la tasa de interés
suba en abril tras tres alzas
consecutivas este año el banco central
en este momento tiene tasas de interés
real negativa porque justamente viene
emitiendo tanto que eso hace que las
tasas de interés de mercado sean más
bajas de lo que deberían hacer
pese a ser un importante productor
mundial de materias primas la américa
latina vive las consecuencias de la
crisis de oferta en el mundo un reto
para los gobiernos mientras crece el
descontento social